people love you know putting women
against each other it's always
you know this and that like it's it's
been happening to me and zendaya since
like we were even
since we started the damn show you know
like it's it's it's no surprise
well let's talk about this movie the
babysitter killer queen
i feel like this movie was such a fun
ride such a fun
sequel how do you feel like it kind of
upped the ante
following the first one i'm so glad you
liked it hell yeah
it was so crazy having everybody back
you know
in this experience again reliving these
characters again
like you know to be able to do a number
two on a project that was
so out there in the first place to get
to work with mcgee again
you know and just be around his lively
sweet endearing energy but yeah we we
did up the ante we up the
ante a lot in this movie we have a lot
of fun
going between a lot of the big jokes
from the first movie kind of bringing
those callbacks
and just changing them a little bit with
new characters all of our new characters
that are in it are just
so fun so out there um
oh my yeah it just it's very funny it's
very good you play allison in these
movies you'll be a
sexy cheerleader if you will i also feel
like
in general and on social media you try
to
generalize women's sexuality which i do
think we need
more of when you do take on a role do
you look for ways to do that
specifically or do you feel like because
of the conversation
you've sort of created you get awkward
roles like that
good question um i think because of the
conversation i've created
people are more likely to offer me roles
like that but i also
think that i've had to do kind of a lot
of pushing
on my own in that sense you know uh just
reading a script i'm like i love this
but you know here's like with the
character we need to add a few more you
know things here and
really make her fully you know
come to life or like you know you're
either
the the pretty girl that you're either
the friend that gets the guy at the end
you're either
you know uh the woman that fights for
what's right but you can't do both
you can't be as a woman on film like a
character that has a million layers like
an onion
why for you has that been an important
conversation and an important just
thing and film to sort of fight for so
much
i feel like almost every female
in the industry has taken that on you
know
we all feel our duty to
do what's right to fight for a better
world for our daughters
um you know to to kind of fight all
these stigmas and all these things and
all these boxes people put us into
and you know you just have to
i feel like no matter what you feel that
in your heart this thing that tells you
know i i have to fight for this
i feel like no matter what i'll always
be you know fighting for it you've come
so far from your disney
shake it up days if you will and so has
zendaya she just got
nominated for an emmy and as we approach
the emmys
do you have a words or any words of of
support for her
um i mean my goodness i just hope she
wins
you know like uh emmy's amazing the show
is amazing i love sam levinson
i i love her so i'm just like you know
i'm gonna have my fingers crossed the
whole entire time i'm just gonna be like
waiting for this acceptance speech i do
feel like
in a way your guys's careers get
pitted against each other i was googling
and i saw this article and it kind of
bummed me out that they
would almost pit you guys against one
another i think that's what people love
to do
right like women you no matter what when
you've got
women and you're on you know you're
growing up in the same market or the
same
you know even just as well other disney
stars
like even if they're not on the same
show you still get pitted
against each other women in general and
just being
under the under the big like overall
thing of disney i think you get it
kind of worse in general and
people are more likely to be like hey
what are you doing
um but yeah i think
people love you know putting women
against each other it's always
you know this and that like it's it's
been happening to me in zendaya since
like we were even
since we started the damn show you know
like it's it's
it's not surprising i honestly don't
really like read
articles and because i'm like i'm just
not gonna
you know really waste my time
hearing their you know negativity and
whatnot because
uh you know i have better things to fill
my head with with growth you know with
some real growth
and i think that when people are you
know uh just really negative
then it's harder to grow you you like
experience that you know
um yeah i love that answer
um and i do love that i do feel like you
are a woman who always supports other
women so
thank you